il est 17h30 badistes jobs a fini sa
journée ce directeur d' agences de
construction métallique à buchelay va
pouvoir se consacrer maintenant à sa
deuxième vie la journée de constructeur
métallique est maintenant terminée et là
je vais pouvoir m'adonner à ma passion
une passion
qui est très prenante également mais qui
est extrêmement importante pour moi
direction rolleboise au domaine de la
corniche baptiste jobs devient jobs
havre et l'artiste d'or et demi par
semaine dans cet établissement
là bas un coin piano est à sa
disposition
alors là on arrive dans mon petit coin
secret dans l'hôtel de la corniche
où je prends un chandelier de l'hôtel
et je m'installe
le piano du bar c'est ici en fin de
compte que j'ai que j'ai écrit que j'ai
peaufiné pas mal de paroles de chansons
notamment celle ci docteur
[Musique]
cette chanson fait partie de son premier
album prologue 15 titres interprétés par
l'artiste avec l'aide de trois autres
musiciens havre et le style job c'est de
ne pas en avoir donc ça peut être
finalement quand je fais l'archange fait
ma route justement jusqu'au havre je
passe un péage d'autoroute et là j'ai
imaginé une histoire d'amour avec une
jolie guichetière au péage ça peut être
les idées qui me sont venues à la suite
du drame du bataclan en une seule nuit
là j'ai imaginé une chanson qui
s'appelle mourir de vivre il a tourné
aussi le clip de sa chanson la mécanique
des sentiments une chanson d'amour
adressée à son piano jobs mène deux vies
différentes qui ne sont finalement pas
si éloigné que ça je pense que je suis
dans la musique un peu comme je suis
dans la construction c'est à dire très
méticuleux très précis parce que c'est
la construction une charpente métallique
ça se prépare quand on arrive sur un
chantier
tout est déjà normalement bien orchestré
pour que ça se passe bien une chanson
c'est pareil après un premier concert au
havre jobs souhaiteraient se faire
connaître davantage dans les yvelines il
est également en préparation du tournage
d'un nouveau clip pour sa chanson un
aller sans retour
et pour toi
ce soit